foreign
as always I'm just honored to be able to
host these conversations as you'll
notice in these recent conversations
we're bringing in some different types
of topics want to kind of keep things
fresh and relevant but also just get the
heart of really some important issues so
today we're jumping in and talking about
black bodies and race and art and
society and I have two wonderful guests
who I think you all are really going to
enjoy hearing from they already had some
good chemistry together off camera
offline so I'm actually really curious
to see where this conversation is going
to go today with this important topic
but by way of introduction I'm going to
go ahead first and introduce Daniel
Swann Daniel is an assistant professor
of Sociology at Goucher College he
completed his Doctorate in sociology at
the University of Maryland and then also
before that earned his undergrad degree
at Rutgers he's taught a whole host of
courses including courses on comparative
social media Generation Z race and
ethnic relations social movements wealth
power and Prestige and also data
analytics to a wide range of topics he
also has academic interests in race
atheism and religion and political
sociology and Social Psychology he's the
author of some books has also
contributed some book chapters one book
I wanted to highlight is his qualitative
study of black atheists don't tell me
you're one of those that was published
in 2020 in addition to the work that
he's been doing he also taught at
University Park Maryland before joining
where he is now so Danny just wanted to
welcome you again to the IDR podcast
awesome it's great to be here
um thanks for having me and yeah of
course chemistry uh you know just makes
me think that things are gonna gonna go
really well so yes I anticipate that as
well
my second guess I would like to
introduce is Iman iMac who is a visual
artist and a scholar of African diaspora
art whose work considers historical and
philosophical issues around the black
body and cultural identity his work has
been exhibited in numerous venues across
the Northeast and the U.S his work is
also represented in the Petrucci
Foundation collection of
African-American art also in the museum
collection of the University of
Massachusetts Amherst his work's been
featured on PBS NewsHour New England
public media and other places as well
and this year in 2023 he has actually
partnered with the medical journal
biological Psychiatry to have his work
appear on the cover of six issues and
that's something that I've been able to
be involved in as well so grateful for
the work he's doing on many fronts
people have someone who actually
graduated from Columbia University in 20
2022 oh my goodness that'd be nice 2002
and then earned his PhD in history of
African-American art at Yale where we
actually overlapped as a grad student so
email thanks so much for being here on
the Eddy Hour podcast
thank you so much wonderful to be what
you need and wonderful to be with you
Daniel
excellent I'm not trying to make you too
young that was just a slip of the tongue
at that point
I don't know if that's good or bad but
I'm just going to leave that one there
hey I
um uh I I uh I teach a writing for art
and the artist course
um at Westfield State University and I
start off the course by showing my
students a paper that was heavily
destroyed by one of my professors when I
was in in college and I put it up and it
said two zero zero one and you heard the
gasps
2001 yeah
yes I I am that old yes yeah yeah we got
that gray going Danny somehow you're
keeping you you're avoiding that so far
so I'm impressed yeah I I graduated
undergrad in 08 so I got a few years all
right you got some time
I'm hoping I follow my other my older
brother's aging patterns so yeah he's he
looks 35 still oh my goodness well if
you learn some Secrets pass them along
so just to jump in as my listeners know
I often just like to do a check-in I
appreciate you all kind of sharing some
of those stories all right but just to
see how you all are doing at this point
in 2023
um with everything that you're doing on
campus everything we're navigating as a
society so Danny if we can actually
start with you that'd be great
yeah
um I'm doing really well
um professionally I have a few things
that I'm working on
um and hope to
finish up a couple of them um during my
sabbatical in 2024
um so I'm really looking forward to that
I've got something coming out on
political rhetoric I've got something
coming out on race and interpersonal
um interactions
um and maybe a group processes thing
coming out too
um really excited about that I've got
some student collaboration going on as
well
um also putting together my 10-year
portfolio here so it's quite yeah the
hectic time
um
but yeah I'm looking forward to getting
all those projects off the desk during
the sabbatical and and out um
so everything there is good my family is
great
um
like you know soccer is a big part of my
life because of my son
um he's awesome shout out to friends
United by the way uh
and uh yeah so everything there is is
just really good
um just chugging along trying to trying
to get this workout yeah yeah that's
great to hear definitely appreciate you
sharing that and not surprising you've
got your hands in so many things with so
many projects going on just from what I
know of you so that's encouraging here
as well hard for me to say no
probably okay thanks for asking though
of course you know what about you yeah
we're played by the same demons in terms
of an inability to say no
um I I thought I had
I thought I'd shaved down what I was
going to be doing for you know about a
year ago I canceled a bunch of things
people were very upset and I am still
overwhelmed there's so much going on
right now
um I'm already planning out into 2024 so
this is gonna be interesting I
um just on the heels of uh the opening
of um the first major comprehensive solo
exhibition of my Studio Projects
um benediction and in his name and um
that that exhibition is titled the hope
of Radiance at um at the August Wilson
African-American Cultural Center in
Pittsburgh it's just it is
it is a stellar exhibition it um it uh
the installation is exquisite I it's Way
Beyond what I expected it to be
um and so that's very exciting um I just
curated a group show that is up at
Westfield State University uh
um titled something extraordinary
um and uh a visual review of story as
Timeless so there are eight African
diaspora artists that I've brought
together to have a conversation about
story
um with their artwork and it's it's a
very expressive amazing exhibition the
art is all very excited to be a part of
it and I'm currently putting together a
group show that will involve myself and
I think it's six other people now but
the the it's called
the miracle machine it's gonna be in the
fall and you don't know what it is we're
doing there's a musician there's three
four artists someone said the title
should be you know four artists a
musician and and a poet walk into a gap
we don't know what we're gonna create
and so UMass Amherst is very excited
we're just good it's gonna be like an
incubator Think Tank space that will
grow over the course of the fall
semester so um
anxiety because I don't know exactly
what will come of it but that's where we
are right now so um other things but
I'll stop there yeah well I appreciate
you sharing that honestly as well I mean
even that's where you know for those who
are listening you know talking on screen
I'm you know thinking about the overlap
between obviously we do work in
different sectors but three black men on
the screen in Academia talking about
taking down lots of different things
trying to make impacts so there's lots
of different directions that we could go
but I definitely appreciate how you all
are have been honest about that and you
know 10-year package coming up all these
art exhibitions coming applying to 2024
I mean there's so many aspects that I
can relate to on that as well just in
terms of things that we've been doing
how far in advance we have to plan
things we have to say no to in order to
say yes elsewhere and so I think even
that sub conversation is is constructive
uh for listeners as we just think about
how we navigate in these different
spaces but even before we get to that
because now you've both talked about
your work a little bit we're just going
to have you all talk about your journey
into your academic professions too
especially as black men and as we also
think about this top like a black body
so you know why don't we start with you
how did you actually get into this work
in the first place
oh
um if there's a storage version
I've always been an artist
um I was uh very fortunate
um I'm product of a of a divorced family
my divorced home that's a part of my
story
um my two um Nigerian parents
um that's a part of my story too and and
so there's there's the
when I came to New York to live with my
mom and I began to um really really jump
into the art my art the art scene
um I I realized that I wanted to go into
this as a as a as a as a as an area and
um she encouraged me so I went to the
High School of Art and Design and
um by the time I graduated I knew I
wanted to go into an academic space that
where art wasn't what I was focusing on
necessarily so I went to Columbia and I
was an art historian there and the field
of art history
um allowed me the chance to
dive into research which is what I
really really wanted to do on some level
but I never stopped making art and so it
was always very very confusing to
um the institutions that I've been a
part of including the one I'm at now
where I'm an art historian I don't teach
Studio Art courses
um how I navigate between the spaces of
art making and art interpretation and I
think that there has been this way that
people have wanted to place me into a
box especially as a black man you can't
be a Creator and an interpreter you
can't be both and I'm like
I can't
white folks do this all the time atmb
curators they curate their own spaces
they but there's something about
um the way I present and I think it has
a lot to do with my big black maleness
that causes people to want to put me in
a particular box they they didn't like
it at Columbia they definitely didn't
like it at Yale and um and at Westfield
I think they've embraced it because
they've seen what can come from it
um uh in real time they've seen it and
so this is a space that I'm still trying
to figure out it's being a very bad art
historian I'm not doing a lot of writing
right now but the work that I'm doing is
certainly contributing to the field and
so
um this is where I am when I speak to
um other students when I speak to
students and other people who are
thinking about diving into art they're
like well how did you do this and how is
it but well this is the pathway that
allowed me to uh this is the pathway I
chose to be a researcher and to do art
not art on the side
but art as really the center
um the creation process as the center of
my research
um and it's informed everything wow I
appreciate you sharing that honestly too
I mean it's just from you know childhood
on there's a lot will definitely come
back to an unpack there
um that you've pulled out but before we
do that just want to jump to Danny real
quick and uh just hear your story too
about you know how you've gotten into
this
this academic Endeavor across so many
different aspects of sociology
um a lot of my own personal interests a
lot of timing and a little bit of luck
so I'll go back
um my parents had uh different religions
uh neither one of them was particularly
convicted neither one of them ever took
me to either place of worship ever so I
grew up without a conception of God okay
time when that was being an atheist let
alone like never have been like believed
in God was seen as very strange
um so that was always something that I
like reading about and stuff like that
so I had that one interest
um at the same time my parents were also
my mom was Jewish my dad's black
um and so there was always really
interesting racial Dynamics I grew up in
an all-black neighborhood my mom was the
only white person in the neighborhood so
I always had lots of interesting things
happening about race and then my mom was
born in the 40s so she was raised at a
time when being Jewish wasn't all the
way encompassed into whiteness yet
later she accepted that she was white
but up until like the 70s she told me
she fought it and um you know so lots of
interesting things there
um
and so I just always wanted to enter you
know explore the intersections of a lot
of those things yeah and uh you know I
was one of the kids that would you know
skip school sometimes to go to the
library because I was really
focused on on learning about these
things so I was reading philosophy books
and all that at a really early age had
aspirations to be a philosopher actually
got to Rutger I went there because at
the time it was the number one
philosophy uh program in the world or
maybe tied with Oxford
and took 16 or 17 philosophy classes
loved my professors
and was the only black kid in every
single classic suffering
and as I started reading this stuff I
was like man this is really stodgy I
don't there were a bunch of issues I had
with it
so right at the end of my
undergrad career I had a bunch of
professors come to me and this you know
this was lucky for me they said we think
you have a lot of potential
um have you ever considered these other
tangentials sort of of careers or
um where you want to go and they suggest
the public policy
um I actually had one put me in touch
with Cornell West who talked to me and
we developed something that I could have
possibly done personal circumstances led
me back to to Maryland and their their
sociology program really embraced me
um and uh something like emo said
um about six one like 215 and I
literally had some of the black
professors in Maryland and this was a
really important part of my life come to
me
you need to know when you walk around
here the way you do and you dress the
way you do that if people are going to
see it a certain way
um doesn't have to be good or bad but
you need to be conscious of it so you
can operate Within These bounds and get
to where you need to go
um Patricia Hill Dr Patricia Hill
Collins is one of those people uh Dr
Chris Marsh who just wrote a book on the
black middle class Called Love Jones was
one of those people Dr Rashawn Ray so
just just having people fall into my
life at the right times
um and then as soon as I got in the
classroom I loved it I could do
and say so many things that I thought
were valuable
um to me in the class and and just since
I ta'd my first class I was like I think
this is such a wow existence to to be a
professor to engage in work that will
eventually trickle into classrooms and
and influence you know what people read
what people think
um and so yeah it was it was sort of
just a path that just sort of
happened before me and I just
yeah definitely appreciate you sharing
that story I mean I think a lot of
people just you know and hearing that
will just be able to gain insight and
maybe even understand that they didn't
have before just you know because
sometimes I know for students when they
walk into our classrooms or see us in
different settings they don't know the
journey to get there so it just helps to
yeah they're all so much better high
school students than I were
um or almost all of them at least yeah
which is scary
as I again just appreciate you you both
sharing that I mean I know we're going
to talk a little bit about um black bias
representation in art and Society but
just with what you both mentioned I just
wanted to lean in a little bit to like
your own experience as black men like
whether what are some of the things
because I know you both talked about
people kind of prepping you for that in
some ways or things that you saw what
are things that surprised you in your
experience and how have you navigated to
thrive
um in a sense
damn maybe we'll reverse it and start
with you this time
um
so again some of the things that
surprised me were just
what was normal to me was not you know
acceptable it was not within the bounds
of what people were looking for and
definitely not what people expected like
I said I almost always went to schools
that were
75 80 percent black um even when I was
in like really advanced programs and so
being smart being articulate those
things were not surprising
and then all of a sudden I get to to
college and people are offended that I'm
raising my hand so much and that I have
opinions and that my God he actually
knows the answer before everybody else
and I I was not ready that
um and so I definitely needed people to
um help me out
um again understanding that navigating
that not letting that bother me
um
and you know not to because those those
are really good and important qualities
for the professor being in Academia and
not to let those qualities you know sort
of be drained out or beaten out of me
so again now that I know what I know as
a sociologist I shouldn't have been
surprised by those but I was you know 17
18 years old I had only had the
experiences that I had uh growing up in
in Prince George's County like I just
showed my my classes now we're talking
about contemporary segregation
where my kids go to school PG County
uh the school system has a hundred and
twenty thousand kids only three percent
White
right and so it's it that is the kind of
experience that I had uh basically and
then again going to these pwi big things
it was it was something that I I needed
help with and like I said I've just been
lucky to have people there
um for me yeah just to follow up a loop
on that how and you talked about this a
little bit about how you uh
helping or informing or guiding your
students in that process too even as you
think about your own experience the
knowledge you have as a sociologist and
paying it forward so to speak
um multiple things
um so one I I and sometimes they ask me
um but I generally dress like this every
day like and and not awful but like in a
way where I'm like living my authentic
Black Box yeah to show them that
you know maybe some of these stereotypes
aren't right and you know I think sort
of just living that every day I know
like Jody armor and Coronel West where
they're afros for the same sort of uh
reason like uh Jody armor says it's his
hoodie right
um and so I try to live it
and I also
um you know through my experiences try
to you know have I've been all over
different demographics because of of my
parents
um
that I can sort of translate a lot of
what I have learned across different
um spaces and so that's really what I
try to do
um in the classroom is Bridge any gaps
use myself as a foil
um so we can just like have a medium to
to talk about these issues um
and yeah so I like I said I I
um
really try to use that that strength in
in terms of across uh different groups
yeah that's that's really good
definitely powerful email anything you
want to add either to answer the
question about your own navigation or
even riff off of anything that Danny
yeah I was just gonna I was gonna
mention the
the notion of serendipity or luck or
like there's
you know for for all the
for all of the intelligence that people
have claimed I have or that I have
thought that I may have had
um I think so so much of my arrival at
where I'm at has come from just the
kindness of just good people people who
people who decided to care at a
particular time the idea that I've
arrived where I'm at by myself
um is uh it's the false one and so I'm I
always find it really interesting when I
encounter you go to a conference or you
speak to people and it's almost like
they've
they've prepared to be doctor so and so
for so long that um uh you get a sense
that
the phone going off for example in the
middle of a of a conversation like this
would be catastrophic right
um and I've just never been able to
arrive at this place where
um where I take myself so seriously
um that uh that I lose my sense of
humanity you know and I think that's
what my students connect with the most
um I will sometimes dress like this in
class and sometimes I'm wearing a
t-shirt because I'm going I'm coming to
class from the studio and I'm going back
to the studio to work and I tell them
what I'm working on I'm like I'm working
on this drawing and it's kicking my butt
right now you know um that's why there's
charcoal on my shirt
um but when I when I was first uh when I
first came in as a professor in 2009
um I thought I was supposed to be
wearing Blazers or a suit or I just had
this feeling that that um because I'm I
teach at a predominantly white
Institution
and there was a sense that it was my
part of my job or burden was to make it
clear that
that I'm worthy of this that as a black
person I can do this and
um and to demonstrate to the white kids
in my class that I really understand my
field and to demonstrate to my
department that I was going to do this
well now
everybody can see everybody could see
and can continue to see now that the
level the level and the quality of work
I was bringing was Way Beyond what they
were even asking for but it was so hard
for me to accept it
um because there was this feeling that
I'm I'm just above water I'm not
actually there and at any given time
um a wave a road wave could come over
and just drown me so when I first got
into Columbia University
um
from The High School of Art design it
was a really really big deal for my high
school
um I was waitlisted Harvard that was a
huge deal you know and I just knew
that they'd made a mistake in fact
the first
two to four I'll say two months of my
time at Columbia University in my dorm
room I waited I waited for notification
for from the head of whoever to say we
made a mistake you're not supposed to be
here because I was struggling when I
first got there I was stumbling through
these classes I was trying to figure out
who I was and all this sea of white
folks and the few black people that were
at school were trying to figure out who
they were to and and there's insecurity
and they're weird things that are said
because of that and it's like I can look
back on it now and be like oh God we
were all so young and stupid and just
trying to figure things out but it still
haunts me some of what I went through
that first semester until I figured out
how to do undergrad and then I when I
got to Yale it was even worse it was
worse because this thing that we study
called art art history
this thing that we study which for me is
not just a thing to study I live it I
roll around in charcoal and paint this
is what I do for fun right
it had become so dry and philosophical
and here I am big black me in the class
and they're asking me a question about
the thing we just read and I'm like did
we all read the same thing
um
because my take was so violently
different
and the way I spoke was so casual and
I'm like this is our I do this every day
like no I don't care if you're using big
words like I do this every day I know
this
and I I just it took me such a long time
to understand that
um
I was just coming from a completely
different world view from most of the
people at these institutions and that it
wasn't my job to change my world view it
was my job to just shine in the way that
I could in myself but it took a while it
took a while I wish I could say that it
was with great confidence and I walked
through the halls of these institutions
but
um even now I shudder as I remember I
shudder as I remember yeah wow well
that's real and I know that people
listening there's gonna be lots of folks
are going to be able to relate to that
too and then also in a sense even get
encouragement from you sharing the
challenges to know that okay if they're
navigating through that it's not just
them because like I mean even as you
describe that there's so much isolation
in how you just describe that even
though you saw other people navigating
those same pieces in isolated pods and I
know my mental health piece is coming
out too but that's that's the first
thing that came to mind as you were
talking definitely I people talk about
the failures enough and I don't think
people I when I say people I mean in
general academics but I think that black
academics in particular should grow more
comfortable discussing the failures
because these spaces haven't gotten any
easier for the next generation of black
and brown people they haven't become
easier we're dealing with the same
things yeah right and um and so the idea
of not sharing my gosh one of the things
I share with my students is I tell them
if you you know if you do well this
semester remind me at close end of the
semester I will tell you my how I almost
got kicked out of Yale story you know
about how the paper that the papers that
I've submitted were so not up to par
because of all of my anxiety that they
almost threw me out I shared this
conversation openly with anyone who will
listen that I graduated got my PhD and
I'm doing very well
but they almost threw me out they almost
threw me out because
I was looking for myself and I it took
me so long to figure out who I was at
that school
um but I'm so comfortable sharing that
I've seen other Scholars cringe when I
talk about I'm like why are you cringing
it's my story yeah yeah somebody needs
this exactly yeah
then anything you want to comment on
either like from your own experience or
your um your lens because you talked
about that too like now what you know as
a sociologist how that also impacted you
looking back and thinking about okay
that's why I was struggling here or
navigating this way any thoughts in
general
for sure
um
and again one it was just like my my
background was very different like
um
both of my brothers were were Street
dudes have been in jail a lot and
um like those are still part of my
influences and
um yeah it just I have something
specific actually yeah so
and again it has to do with with
mannerisms and what's normalized and
what's taught so
um again grew up
talking
conversing a certain way
and for whatever reason again maybe it's
because
of where I went to school never had
grammar in any level of school not in
third grade not in fifth grade not in
ninth grade not in 12th grade never
never right so I'm in all these AP
language classes in high school and like
I write well so I'm getting like B's but
I'm always getting my papers all marked
up and whatnot
um and then I get to college and the
compository writing
um or expository writing I forget what
the name of the class was
um
I'm getting really good grades in that
and my teacher is really impressed with
the way that I can interpret passages
and all of that and she even assigns me
to help a couple students in the class
that are struggling
and then we take a final in that class
which isn't graded by the professor but
graded by the a random grad student in
the English Department
and
it's graded very technically and I
failed that final
first semester freshman year I had all
A's in other classes so I was like I can
do this
but it was this
thing that I was never taught
and combined with the fact that how I
normally talk
and normally right is is culturally
alien to a lot of
that I ended up failing that class and
that you know again my my mom was really
supportive of me in that my dad was
really supportive of me my other
professors were really supportive of me
um to not let that get me down
um but my second semester I had to
repeat a class right and I still ended
up graduating with honors in philosophy
and sociology
um but those trials are real and a lot
of times just aren't prepared for them
and you can't know
unless you have somebody who has the the
experience and knowledge we can't really
know
that you're not prepared for for certain
spaces and so yeah
wow okay I got an A in the class the
second time yeah
wow I mean that's really that's really
poignant but I mean
I'm trying to figure out how to say this
but it just speaks to the whole that
whole meritocracy
yeah commentary that I know a lot of
people have been having that
conversation some might hear us and say
oh we're hearing this again but I still
think sometimes people just don't want
to admit
that's because you know that you know
you had another ta everything shifted at
the last minute and someone from the
outside could be like oh well he just
didn't
earn the same x y and z's are about
ignoring the fact of what you were
exposed to early on how that impacts you
in that situation and how the other
Professor was giving you feedback like
all of that and then how that's just
used to kind of you know keep people in
their place for lack of a better word so
yeah yeah I still can barely use a comma
or semicolon yeah drop them in there
haphazardly and let editors fix it now
yeah no
yes somebody needs to hear that
somebody's gonna need to hear what you
just said because
um
um yeah yeah it's it's such a it's I
wish that I could look back on all of
these experiences with fondness but
there was so much of it that was uphill
fighting
um for me and um and so like
I uh but I do look at my undergraduate
experiences with with fondness because
like I said there were people who chose
to just be kind they saw a diamond in
the rough and so it but it was I I bring
this up because it was those decisions
that certain people made you know um
Adam Rothman who was at that time a PhD
student teaching a course and he's doing
big things now
um but like he pulled me aside he's like
when I see an a I'll give you one here's
what you need to do and um a lot of my
issue was scaling back how much I was
saying because I was able to get to the
Crux of my arguments much faster with
shorter papers there were two different
professors that pulled me aside and said
oh God you're doing this all wrong you
wrote seven pages here but the last four
pages were were brilliant the first two
made no sense and so like someone had to
teach him
how to harness what they all said was a
gift for writing they all sent no no no
you're one of the best fighters we've
ever seen at your at this stage I'm like
I am but yes then why would I have an A
because this is a terrible paper
but we can see what you can do and so
pull me aside and showing me line by
line
but it took time it took time and and so
now as a professor I it I remember that
I remind myself of that and my students
I show them my old papers and I sit with
the ones who really want to know and we
go through it line by line um until we
understand you know how we can be better
you know um but I can't this
for anybody who would say you know oh
you know well that has nothing to do
with race you're making everything about
race like why are you talking about race
why would you bring up race in this kind
of instance because race was such a big
part of that
um the fear of speaking in those white
spaces uh because
you felt like anything you said would
represent your entire race you know
having certain professors pull me aside
and say Iman you've been really quiet in
class lately why and not being able to
admit that I heard two white girls
snickering in the corner when I was
speaking and immediately thought that I
sounded stupid the professors had to
find ways to get me to speak and then
once I once I was open it was like it
was it was over you know but it it race
is so much apart still
um of um this college experience
um especially for uh for um for for
black men in in schools such as these
yeah yeah
really well said and I appreciate again
just how open you are with your students
too and just kind of taking them on that
Journey Daniel you look like you're
gonna reflect on something oh no I I
just really agreed with what he said
yeah yeah to try to employ a bunch of
the similar practices yeah can I say one
more thing yeah yeah there were these
moments I know we're talking about black
bodies and or we will or we already are
and there were these there were
I don't remember every moment of my time
at these institutions
um but there are a couple that stand out
to me and it was one when I was at Yale
in the the in the music the music
library is easily one of the most
extraordinary beautiful
things ever constructed it's just such a
beautiful space you know so I would just
go in there sometimes and just
sit there you know
um and and and and I remember
um and and there were these moments
where I would completely forget who I
was in this space and it was one
particular time I was walking by in
there just I greeted somebody really
warmly and they just looked me up and
down and um and I um
it's like okay and then I I went to the
bathroom and I caught my reflection I'm
seeing this
big black always sweaty there's a sweat
on my face book bag and I'm just like
damn I've got
I remember that moment when I was I saw
myself in the mirror
I'm like
damn
like why would anybody not greet me or
be or smile you know and and I was just
reminded in that space it's like so I
negro to change your space you know
that's how I felt there and um I had a
few moments like that but this is one
that just I'm reminded of it's not that
it was all gloom and doom I had
wonderful things that happened in these
institutions to there
um in undergrad studio venkatesh uh I
realized that my way into
um art history my way into art history
as a study what okay my way into
research of art history happened through
ethnography happens
um opened up my whole world view like
I'm like wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait so I could study
African and African-American artists as
a sociological project and he had me to
an independent study with him it's not
not easy
um but he walked me through that slowly
methodically carefully
um and brought me to this place where I
could begin to understand how art
history and sociology and Archeology and
and all of these things are very very
they're not as divided as you would
think depending on what it is you're
trying to study as an africanist in art
history these things are all very very
connected and so I had good moments I
just want to make it clear that the Race
part is not something that's easily
um uh divorceable yeah it's part of it
yeah
I'll add one real quick thing and that
is
um both of us went to
went to undergrad like at like the peak
of like color blindness in this weren't
supposed to talk about those things
right that's when they were like I'll
get the chip off your shoulder or
whatever
um I think there's now a little more
space we're talking about those sorts of
experiences
um but again like 15 20 years ago
um there there really wasn't
um
so yeah yeah that's a really good point
just I mean just to pick up on that a
little bit too because the one thing we
were going to talk about just like how
you all
think about these topics in your current
roles both what you do in the classroom
and like how it impacts Society so Danny
I was just going to follow up with you
like how does that because you I know
we've talked a lot about you know the
wealth Gap pieces and some of those
other things and how you introduce your
students to those Concepts so how do you
think about I mean this isn't exactly
what you do but how you think about the
concept of a black body even as you're
teaching all these different classes on
all these intersecting topics and how
you kind of pass that on to your
students to really make sure they catch
the realities
right good
um one of the things I try to drive home
across all of the different subjects
that we cover is that there is
so much evidence that there is a social
and racial hierarchy in this country uh
blacks the most consistent thing is that
black people are at the bottom right and
so I try to depending on what
um we're covering that week or whatever
relate something to that right and so
um like today we were talking about
um implicit bias right and to literally
show
um an experiment done of you know here's
a white kid acting this way in a park
here's a black kid acting this way in a
park
what are the reactions of the the
society around gonna be
the way that black bodies are treated in
each and every single
you know scenario for the most part is
different and almost always
qualitatively worse right there are some
times where I show them stuff and they
they think it's white guilt and that not
necessarily worse or better but most of
the time they think that it's
qualitatively
um worse and so that's that's what I try
to
sort of get across right
um and even in that that one specific
video right it it just debunks so many
stereotypes that white people are
supposed to be scared of these like
while in thugs or whatever right
um when in reality it's almost always
the black body that's put in Jeopardy by
acting anyway outside of the norm doing
something deviant that um a white kid is
allowed individuality
um and not funny about those things that
that black bodies are often in really
vulnerable really vulnerable positions
and often in really vulnerable positions
where authority figures
have the ability to do something to them
right spend them from school
arrest them put them in jail right these
sorts of things
um and that just cumulatively
it adds up to so much right it adds up
to stress it adds up to lower life
expectancy it adds up to
um you know building up all these
stereotypes about black deviants and
criminality when it's treated different
from the beginning
and so yeah I just
I I insert
body so they can like really understand
and empathize rather than just see a
bunch of numbers like when I show
numbers on the wealth disparity they
don't want to believe it the wealth
disparity is 10x it's been 10x for 50 60
years I'll give them a quiz they don't
want to they just don't want to know
they'll still put two times or four
times right
um but when it actually
am able to get them to visualize
um
bodies or hypothetical people it clicks
better
um
wow
wow yeah I'm still I'm still still
taking that in yeah
get it wrong on the test because I
refuse to hear it
and it's been very consistent that one
question especially across it's very
telling yeah it's very very telling it
says it all
okay I um on my end uh you know that I
mean the courses I teach but they're
also the special projects that I do
um and and just by way of this
conversation we're having about black
bodies there was one that I I did at
Westfield State University which is like
I said a predominantly white school and
I should tell you that I did here's how
I arrived at this project it's a project
titled 17 years boy and um
I still don't know what that project was
and I'm glad it's over to be honest with
you but before that project started
here's what had happened all right um
Donald Trump had recently been
inaugurated as president
determined at another time if any of the
following things were connected to him
um there was this huge Charlottesville
you know incident
um it was brought upon by riots by um
white nationalists and white
supremacists and there was a whole lot
of
a whole lot of wickedness that looked
white there okay
um
um in Charlottesville and and and and
and people died one person died two cops
died three people died of a leaf net in
that
um so that it happened
someone in my church a church I no
longer attend in predominantly white
church white Evangelical Church
um had posted a news to his Facebook
page public
um he says in response to Black lives
matters and all of a sudden because
treason they'll say you know they're
they're yeah now you know no no no no no
not lynching
traditional way of you know freeziness
would be so it's a news no well yeah we
don't see history of black people with
news today but that's not what I meant
so he posted that to his Facebook page
um I was
I won't go into that story but a number
of things happened and didn't happen as
a result of that
um and then school starts and two weeks
into school starting
um uh
students are a black students are
accosted with
um racist language written on their on
their doors go home
um or live here or whatever it
was it sounded very very 60s it's really
interesting how the language hasn't
changed much so
um you know and so all of these things
are happening
um
and
they're people planning marches because
of the racist incidents at Westfield
State their people there were rape
threats to black black girls that were
all kinds of things were happening that
that semester in particular was hot but
it wasn't just at Westfield State it was
happening around the United States okay
at a number of different institutions
and so I decided to have a project that
would look at the life and death of
Trayvon Martin
um because people are asking are you
gonna be at this are you going to be at
this protest are you going to be at this
I'm like I everybody leave me alone you
all go ahead and do your marching
whatever's gonna make you feel better
um but I'm gonna do what artists do we
make things and so I brought together it
was a collaborative project that
involves the
um the the 17 hour long it took four
days to do painting of a portrait of
Trayvon Martin that was destroyed at the
17th hour nobody knew it was gonna be
destroyed it was an extremely emotional
um work of art
um and many people are still wondering
what happened people were asking well
why is he doing this the people who were
criticizing it were like this doesn't
make any sense people that was that was
like six years ago but it was weird in
the room that I constructed you could
hear the sounds of the Zimmerman trial
like that was playing so it was like you
were walking into a Time Warp we were
six years prior we were all living in
that moment where this boy who was
brutalized
um me
was not was dragged through the
Zimmerman trial became the Trayvon
Martin trial we all lived through that
about how he could be killed twice you
know and so there was this conversation
about black bodies and the things that
happened to us and why you know graffiti
on doors such as go home or
live here in then 2017 2018
really you can draw a line to it and
it's a national one and it's a local one
and um it confused a lot of people a lot
of people felt good that it was
happening as well
um and I was completely devastated when
a very very high ranking person at the
school when it was all done came and
said this is this has just been amazing
you when are you gonna do it again
wow
I looked at him
here we have put together art the music
department had come together The English
Department there were songs it was a
very emotional thing
in commemoration of Trayvon Martin but
also of 17 other boys over the past
Century starting from 1915 who had had
things like this done so it was like it
was a shrine
and this man came to me and said please
imaw we need to do more of this when are
you going to do this again I was like I
don't know let's see the next the next
boy is going to be killed next week
let's let's put it together again it was
very odd and missing the mark you know
and so there is this way that I can
imagine that Danny has has poured
himself out into a lecture or into a
work of a piece of writing
um or or into a talk
um only to have this the point just
oh yeah just gone and you wonder are you
shouting into a void that just consumes
what it is you're saying it it is there
any way that change happens is what I'm
doing does it actually move the the does
it does it move anything no and that's
something that I wonder often I mean I'm
still when I get off when I'm done with
you guys I'm I'm going I'm working on
the next thing because the conversation
has to continue but there is this here
are some times that
um people are seeing the Artistry and
missing the point that worries me
absolutely
um I've had a number of instances like
that
um
and
yeah it is tough to deal with
um I would say that like that's where
like
individual emails or something like
maybe a text from a student even if it's
later be like
I get it now
um are really valuable
um resources to you know
keep you going
yeah
yeah that's I mean it's sobering but
like those little pieces those little
things like I said make a huge
difference so
yeah
well one thing just a is a last pivot
I'm curious that now I'm really curious
just the way this conversation is gone
I'm curious what keeps you all going
like what gives you hope and what you're
doing because I mean we've talked about
I mean there's obviously the the passion
for the craft that you have but there's
also the challenges and you've done a
nice job of kind of laying out that
reality but just I'm sure our listeners
are curious too like why are you all
still doing this work what what keeps
you moving besides those texts and those
messages
Dan do you want to start
it's the it's not the huge Academia
checks either
um
the collective laughter about it
oh God you're relatively okay but we're
not buying any uh NFL franchise anytime
so there are like real world tangible
things that give me hope right I've seen
since I've started doing my work uh with
atheists specifically black atheists
there has been some stigma lifted around
that and that especially within the
black community I've seen some of that
stigma lifted and I think even at least
as importantly some of that more secular
public figure
um black history reclaim
um so I
um in terms of seeing more black faculty
and
certain institutions really trying to
live up to ideals like I do have hope
from those things
um and so I try to to lean into that
that
um you know that there is hope to fix
the things that have been really slow
right like
actual
fixing or narrowing of of racial
disparities that has been slow going if
if no going at all right Clarity
homeownership Gap those things are
bigger than when Dr King spoke in 1963.
um
but the progress that I see on the
interpersonal side again lends me to
just just want to keep chopping and hope
that we can have enough
cross-cultural understandings and
eventually some Paradigm shifts that
lead to places where we start to see
outcomes being more evil we start to see
the qualitative treatment of different
groups being much more equal much less
disparate
and so that's that's really the world
that I'm hoping for
I think that it's achievable I've seen
individuals make the change
um
so that's what gives me hope the thing
that you know scares me is
um just just how incentivized racism has
become on the right wing especially
um and that
that is a a very strong competing Force
to what I want to see
um and it has a lot of money and it has
a lot of power and it has a lot of
structural things going for it in terms
of minoritarian government prevailing
quite a bit in this country
um and so yeah
um
I hope that makes sense right now I've
got to overcome that obstacle because of
the things that I've seen
um within people especially
um again some institutions was the
institutions have been very slow to to
change in this Society yeah and I
definitely appreciate that perspective I
mean as I'm reflecting what you're
saying it actually reminds me of the
story you were talking about with the
wealth Gap and how you just you're
continuing because that's a microcosm
the students might not be seeing it at
first you package in a different way
eventually they catch it and just
hearing you talk about that on the
societal level in terms of stigma for
black atheists or other types of things
that are moving at the individual level
institutionally
that gives me hope hearing you say that
because I know that's attention
that I feel often especially I know even
in this podcast like okay or what am I
doing in the lab what am I doing with
students is making a little difference
here is it making a difference
society-wide
where where and that's this almost it
almost sounds too selfish in a sense
because it's almost as if I'm saying
where am I feeling like I'm actually
making an impact in someone's life or in
someone's lives or in society so the
kind of hear you package that for me is
also just really helpful it reminds me
of something I I said to my wife
um when about two or three weeks ago
there was the Fallout of Beyonce not
winning a Grammy I don't keep up with
the awards I think it was a Grammy
and I said to her well I don't I didn't
listen to that album but she did I heard
it in the background it was okay
um but I said to her 30 years ago we
wouldn't have even had a public business
about should a black woman have won a
Grammy yeah so we need to acknowledge
what's what's racist what kind of bias
are going on over there but also that
there is hope because we are in a
different space than we we used to be
yeah that's good perspective
I'm gonna give you the last word my hope
is in the relationships that
um that I'm forming with I think some of
the most extraordinary people
um as I create
um and as I
deal with the various themes you know um
in my work as an artist as a professor
and just as as a human being so the
relationships bring hope for me
um I'm not working in a vacuum things
are happening the world is moving
um uh
and
what I do as an artist is
just another offering
um it's another offering and an opening
for a conversation
um I I sometimes find
it easier to deal with my emotions
around a series of things you know um
through the Avenue of Art and what what
I like about it is that I I don't always
know what I'm doing in fact most of the
time I don't I don't do sketches before
I do the final work I just it comes out
as a unit it's how I work
um and and it's pretty honest when it
does it's
perhaps more honest and more honest in
line than I am
um than I am when I'm speaking and uh
there's something childlike about about
making things starting with nothing and
then making it
um there's something a little
narcissistic about it I'm deciding that
that is going to be something when
anybody looking at it can say there's
nothing there right and so somewhere in
that tension between the God complex and
a child
um is the opportunity for a new kind of
conversation to start and
um
because God is always making you things
I just don't know what it's going to
look like I don't know what to do and
there's hope in not knowing if that
makes any sense like so you know we
think that you know we think we
we think we know what the next five
minutes will bring right and fact is we
don't
there's somewhere in there that
gives me hope you know
um that something really extraordinary
could take place
um I think it's childlike but I'm okay
with that in terms of being a teacher or
Professor
um it's still in the relationships I was
teaching I I when I teach my art survey
courses it's a general course in in art
history
um I always start with Africa I have my
reasons
um I've never
been a part of an art survey course in
my training that is started with Africa
I start with Africa and and we go
through it and
um I have in one of my classes I have
one one black kid one blacks two two
black students and this one guy he's
just he's just sharp he's a brilliant
young man he's a first year and I was
talking about something I forgot it was
a video showing of some ritual or
ceremony there were women dancing and I
was talking I was trying to stay focused
but I panned the room as I was giving
this impassioned end of the lecture and
the smile on his face he was just
looking at the screen it looked
cartoonish
he he was beaming ear to ear and he
waited till after class to meet with me
and he's like
I don't know how to look I'm I'm
African-American you know that's Africa
there's got to be some kind of genetic
memory I know those women I know how
they're moving I get that like I I feel
like I'm related to them so he was
explaining he didn't know that I saw
this big grin on his face but he was
explaining how he was feeling in that
moment and I'm like
I'm supposed to be at this school right
now
he needs this and there are students
like him that need this right now and so
there's hope in that for me there's hope
that I'm in the right position at the
right place in time
um that that that that that that my
being in this particular moment mean
something to the people um who are
gathered around me
um and I'm okay
with just that um
it's a great juxtaposition from the the
undergrad not feeling like yeah to be
here to
that moment giving you the exact
opposite um feeling of I should be here
and this is exactly why
yeah yeah it's awesome
great illustration wow
well I'm grateful to both of you one for
just the work that you all do on a daily
basis I mean even
not despite but amidst everything that
you all navigate just to even to get to
where you are as you all share it so uh
so powerfully and eloquently and then
just the impact it's having on that
generation definitely full circle as
Danny mentioned so
thank you to both of you for the work
thank you for taking time out of your
schedules to actually be here to share
this I know listeners are going to get a
lot out of this and I'm just
anticipating there's so many things that
people are going to be able to relate to
or have their eyes open to at the same
time or a little bit of both so
definitely appreciate what you're all
doing hopefully this will give other
people hope as well as we all try and
move forward as a society so Danny email
thanks so much for being here definitely
appreciate both of you awesome thank you
I had a blast I had a blast too
[Music]
thank you